ううっう0
今から日本語の講座を行います
少子高齢化につきましてはまぁ多少心配してはいますがそれが我が家も家計に悪い影響
を与えることはあんまりないと思いますというのは国日本に住んでいてもはめ理科の
国籍を持っていれば
簡単に米国市場に投資できますので右肩上がりの成長を期待しています
そうですね骨上場投資信託ですね
景気が良くても多角化が必要ですよね
金価格の引き上げですか何を吸われますか
そうですね私はワイだけ日本は
子供は少ない
ません
たしスタークを日本語で何を言いますか
天八かで
姥ケをお金に
思います
道元さんの国民健康保険の加入手続きは以上です
これで俺に保険がついてるっていうことですよね
はい健康保険は健康保険は運転する予定であればあそか車の保険もいるんだよねはい
自賠責保険と new おけ
ですでも兄だったら加入しなくていってことですよね
必要になりますじゃあなんで22保険って言うんですか雇用保険に入りました
8 youtube やってるんで空になることをちらの医療保険にも加入しますか
いやさっき健康保険に入ったんでちなみにがん保険は別なります
がんになっても普通の健康保険で払えるんでしょ
の火災保険に入りました入ります地震保険は一生じゃないんですか水漏れ保険はや
もっとあるし別途保険は何も買ってません念のためにね hype 生命保険は入る
予定です加えて飲んだちょっと待って損害保険自転車保険ばいる法華
保険ホッケー
me
ずよって
お久しぶりん
みんなどこ
おばあさんちょっといいですか何かね
もうここで10分も待っていますが電車がまだ来てません
この電車ってどのぐらいの頻度でくるかわかります
お兄さんするメール会やおばあさんここの電車が道内のいいのでくるかわかりますか
1時間1回1時間2階ですか
最後の電車月きたか分かります11分ま一変きちゃったんで大丈夫
太郎君がいるから太郎くんこの役に三者
その人が電車を選んでくれるって事ですかいや
太郎君は猫だからとロウ君こっちする名手
あってきたか
です
レーション残りほど九電さは列車が一つしかない
乗客はもうほとんどいないからねこれ
貸切じゃんほんとすげー俺おばあさんをのないですかいいえ私はた6に会いに行った
だけじゃ
23する見るかいいフィリませんどこで降りるかええっ
お式と色度じゃそこは6時役だから
宇治駅吉報神バスケットに入れると良い駅で働いている人が誰もいないってことですか
bar 助っ人が改札にかかってるからおばあさんスルメを1個もらってもいいですか
2本持って行きなさいん
ni